[Music]
the work I'm going to present today is
about the collaboration I was making
together with the WH o that means World
Health Organization and it was based on
helping them to understand what was
happening in the in the low and middle
income countries regarding mental health
just before defining all their policies
and intervention activities and their
development planning's
to all those countries regarding mental
health so most of you know what WH o is
this is the reference the reference
entity regarding health all over the
world is the one that is providing the
guidelines on health in the different in
the different aspects let's say and in
that case this is a collaboration with a
specific department does the department
of mental health and substance abuse and
the reason the reason for this
collaboration was because after many
many years of making intervention
activities in low and middle-income
countries on nutrition and help in
vaccination and helping all those health
care systems to decrease infections
mortality and all those sort of things
they didn't get the expected impact on
Reda redacting the neonatal mortality
right so after many years they
discovered that the problem was not
about nutrition nor about the main cause
of this neonatal mortality was not that
much more nutrition and vaccination and
infections and all those but that the
postpartum major depression of a big
part of the mummies
was having a direct impact on that so
those that knows about mental health
knows that major depression has a big
symptom a big effect that is decreasing
of volition of the of the capacity of
executing the things you are thinking
about so depressed person is in in the
bed in the morning tell him telling
himself I have to wake up I have to
stand up and go to work and he just stay
it at on the bed and and don't do the
action so you can imagine a mummy with a
major depression with a kid of two days
life crying and asking for the milk and
she was sitting somewhere saying I have
to wake up and take the kid and giving
the milk and Dawn doing it right so in a
couple of days
those small kids didn't survive anymore
so at that point WH I realized that
mental health is a relevant matter also
in underdeveloped countries when I was a
child I was told that all these mental
problems were part of the development
work world and not that much of of the
sub developed countries and at that
moment they decided that they had to
take care about mental health as well so
at that point they were trying to
understand what was the starting
situation to make the diagnosis of what
was done or not and mental health in the
different Lambie countries just to
understand what was required to do right
and to do that they were first of all
designing a specific instrument that's
called the who aims questionnaire that's
a questionnaire about two hundred and
fifty six variables this is not big data
okay
that was querying the country about
about the different different domains
that are written here then we have a
second source of information that was
not
that much data but knowledge the now how
of the experts on what was happening in
each one of those countries and then we
have some extra synthetic indicators
that the the technicians from the w-h-o
were building as a composite
calculations on the original data that
we're measuring things on top of which
they reason when they are evaluating the
countries right so this is three
different kind of information three
different kind of sources not all of
this is data not all of this is easy to
be represented as a columns in a data
set and the main goal was to understand
what was happening to me diagnosis and
to help those w-h-o experts to make the
decisions and develop the policies on
what to do in the different countries so
first problem here was that we have
about one-fifth of missing data most of
the people working with data are used to
so this is not new for people that work
in in in data this was propagated to all
the calculations and all the synthetic
indicators and so the first thing we had
to do so first thing we had to do was to
work on on the pre-processing then we
had to we decided to provide a typology
so to identify profiles of countries
with similar situation regarding the
mental health care systems and finally
we were working very much someone was
talking here but visualization and how
to represent the results to talk to the
experts and so on that's critical on my
point of view as soon as you have
stakeholders that are not have not
technical skills and are placed in the
higher levels of the physicians they
have very few technical skills and they
don't want to have technical skills so
it's very very important how do you
present the information to them in order
to bridge the gap in between what data
is telling you from the technical point
of
view and these effective decision-making
crosses right and that's part of the
thing I will talk to you so first thing
we did was to develop a particular a
specific method of missing data
imputation that we are using from some
years ago now because we had very few
time and as you know in missing
imputation we have always this trade of
him between the precision of the of the
imputation of the data and the time we
need to build that imputation models at
that moment we were designing something
that was in the middle and I will give
some clues on that and this is more or
less the process right this is a
classical data science process where you
start by identifying you which are your
inputs then you have some issues related
to pre-processing in that case on the
data mining step we were using a
particular kind of clustering that we
already developed some years ago and I
will talk about that then we spend quite
a lot of time on this post-processing
and the result of that was some new
knowledge about what is happening in the
mental health systems and that was
concreted in in three different three
different outcomes one was to understand
which are the dimensions along which
this complex system like a mental health
care system is evolving around which
were these profiles of these types of
mental health systems that appear in the
different countries and a sub product
that was quite useful was a kind of
pathology kind of neo ontology that is
describing all these mental health care
systems in low and middle income
countries with a specific vocabulary
that is different from the one the
experts were using in the in the mental
health in in developed countries so
regarding the the pre-processing I think
the most important part was this was
this missing imputation data
since we had a few time what we decided
was to get first of all a subset of
relevant variables that were quite full
okay and we were using the expert to
impute in an expert based in an expert
based way those missing data that were
very few and after that we were using
this first full data matrix to make an
initial clustering to find profiles of
countries and then to use the local
means to impute all the other missing
data to these using these local means
right so I'm going to go through that
method quite quick you have a
publication that describes the method
here and you have the reference in the
in the slides and the most the main
advantage of dust of that thing is that
it has a very good trade-off in between
the accuracy of the obtaining missing
values estimators and the required time
to complete the data set and to get a
fully fully data a full data matrix that
you can process in the data mining step
so the nice thing here okay
with the experts we were selecting these
core variables that has a small amount
of missing data so they could work
manually on the missing data of this
subset of data they were in that case we
had very very few missing data this
requires some meetings with the experts
some meetings with the experts
discussing which were reasonable values
for these empty cells in the data set
and this was concerns weighted
estimation this can be done of course if
you have a few number of cells that
require this kind of
of treatment and the very very
interesting thing that outcome from that
process is that we discovered that these
experts were using basically two
mechanisms for imputing those missing
data that map on the missing data
methods that we normally use on an
automatic way one of those is what we
called vertical imputation vertical
imputation was used in the following
ways so the experts were checking on the
same variable another country that they
knew it behaves in the similar way as
the one we are trying to impute and they
were reasoning by analogy right so this
is more or less so for example in in
China the rate of other medical doctors
was missing so since they knew this is a
very institutional system they were
finding another country with a mental
health based on institutional system and
they were using those values to make the
estimation right on do and this is more
or less what we do when we are using the
KNN method for imputing the missing
values we are finding a closest element
in my data set and I am more or less
copying or adapting the values of these
closest neighbor nodes so this this is a
parallelism with the KNN imputation
method on the other side for other
countries they were reasoning in another
way and and we were talking about
original imputation in that case they
were using other variables of the same
country that can be more or less
predictors of the variable that is
missing right so and that's what we do
with the regression based imputation
methods and AAA expectation maximization
and so on so that was
the second part this was providing I'm
skipping that one this was providing a
full date mattress and on top of that
full data matrix we were making a
clustering using some particular
parameters that I will comment
afterwards we were getting our
hierarchical tree most of you know that
hierarchical clustering is quadratic so
it's not directly scalable to Big Data
in that case would have small data and
we can do that when we have to use this
kind of methods for big data we just
connect this with a CUDA strategy I
don't know if you know the CUDA strategy
but it's based on some time something
like a bootstrap method on the
hierarchical clustering and it's scaling
the quadratic complexity of building the
dendrogram to the big data scenario so
even with big data we are using this
imputation method right so in that case
we got a list of clusters okay a list of
clusters based on those original
variables that are more or less basic
and with few missing data that the
experts were providing and here you
already understand that we have already
biased the process towards the knowledge
of the expert right because they have
been selecting the variables they have
been providing the imputation of the
missing data so expertise having in all
our methodologies an important an
important role and is transferring their
knowledge on the problem to that system
in many many different steps of the
whole methodology that we use in these
kind of problems in that case here we
had an intermediate step of improving
the data quality so at that point
experts could understand which were the
countries that were appearing in wrong
clusters and they could check on the
original data in for example it was
and expect that that Burundi was
classified originally with the cluster
with Uruguay Chile and Panama so at that
moment Burundi was the poorest country
in the world Chile was one of the best
position countries in the lamech domain
because it was it was about about
shifting to the next development
developing levels so this was crushing
all the ideas and when we checked we
discovered that Burundi has falsified
all data and have been providing a lot
of very nice raids and indicators and
percentages and everything so this step
was had a side effect that was improving
the quality of data and permitted to
make some Corrections and some things
and we continued with the better data
set than we had at the beginning okay
after that we could compute the
conditional means of all the variables
regarding those clusters and these were
the imputation values that we were using
for each one of these variable in each
one of the clusters when there was a
missing value right so this is an
adaptation of the conditional mean of
the conditional mean method imputation
method that is multivariate and permits
to use this conditional imputation
taking into account the interactions
between many different variables before
instead of using only one so that was
working well and then the second the
second step on pre-processing was about
deciding which were the features to be
included in the definite profiling step
that we were about to to follow at the
second step and then we were taking as
well all those all those synthetic
indicators that the experts were using
to ordinarily evaluate how
Mental Health System was performing so
this is again a way to transfer
knowledge the Miss Pacific common
knowledge into the problem so for
example there is one index that is
called a lund parameter that is a kind
of ratio and this is a nonlinear
relationship between two between two
variables that were measured on the
original question that's a ratio between
the external contacts that the patient
has with the mental healthcare system
with regards to the days that he has
been spending in the hospital and the
recovery in the mental health unit right
for the experts this is an this is an
index that is giving is scoring the
mental health system towards the mental
health approach so it tells to the
experts
if mental health patients are basically
trade under a Social Inclusion approach
and stay at home us not just possible
and try to be working with the social
workers and get therapies that permits
them to follow morale as a normal life
instead of being recruited in mental
health hospitals with aggressive
therapies and isolation and all these
sorts of things so this is more or less
the old way of treating of treating the
mental health patients this is more or
less though the more modern approach so
this is something that you cannot catch
from a regional data okay so but this is
something that is very close to the
reasoning way in which the experts
evaluate what is happening in a system
and how they make the diagnosis so in
the pre-processing step that most of you
know that is one of the most longer
along any data science projects whenever
you can catch this kind of things and
you can build new variables that contain
this kind of aggregated concepts that
the expert
sorry using to reason about their moon
their domain it is very effective to
create the variables that represent
these concepts and to including to the
analysis because this makes the final
results of the model to be more close to
the reasoning to the reasoning system of
the expert and makes easier that the
results of the of the model are easily
understandable by the by the experts and
easily used in decision-making right
after that and so we expend as usual
about seventy percent of the total life
of the of the project into
pre-processing and these sorts of things
and after that we were moving to
building the model and in that kind in
that case since our goal was to
understand how where these mental health
care systems we were proposing to build
the top a typology so we were moving to
a clustering algorithm and we were not
using a traditional hierarchical
clustering algorithm but what we called
clustering based on rules clustering
based on rules is a clustering method
that this injecting prior knowledge on
the problem into the clustering process
itself just to guarantee that the
results of the clusters fit well in what
is already well known in the problem
right so this is a semantic bias that we
are introducing in the clustering
process in that case the semantic bias
is introduced through a classical
knowledge base and that means that we
introduced some rules given by the
experts of course in that case we are
only using concentrate in knowledge I
mean this is not about using subjective
rules that might change between one
expert and the other one in that case we
had a big set of international delegate
of experts that were concentrating or
we're agreeing in which part of the
already concentrated knowledge on the
problem could be useful and they were
providing us basically three inputs not
that much so we are very far from the
old knowledge expert systems from the
eighties in which you needed a complete
definition of the domain based on rules
in order to guarantee that the system
was reasoning in the in the correct way
so we are here relaxed relaxing the
requirement of complete description of
the domain we need not a complete
description of the domain just a partial
one the important thing is that partial
description of the knowledge is based on
really well-established knowledge okay
and in that case there were three things
that they were they were expressing and
that we were translating in form of
rules as in this step of knowledge
engineering let's say that were
basically all those countries that come
from the ancient United you know Soviet
Union had an old-fashioned approach for
the mental health
okay so electroshocks therapies and
reclusion on hospitals and all these
sort of of approach of the mental health
was very very much
installed in the russian in the in the
soviet union countries and so when the
soviet union was disagreeing
disaggregating those countries were
still very much influenced by this kind
of approach another thing that they were
transferring to us is that the the most
poor american countries had a particular
way of treating mental health that's
different from the other countries and
the other thing was that small asian
countries also were behaving in a more
Yentl what is so in a more particular
way okay so we were using this knowledge
that's not that much to get that
knowledge from experts so when we move
to other domains we still talk to
experts and try to get this kind of
prior knowledge about any kind of domain
then we were using the data coming from
the coming from the instrument and also
those synthetic indicators and some
other data coming from the World Bank
that we are describing more the economy
of the countries and so on and we were
running the clustering based on rules
and we got a hierarchy of countries that
could be cut in a certain place using
the appropriate criteria to define the
clusters of countries right so the
clusters of countries where those these
seven profiles here we have the
countries belonging to each one of this
profile and then we moved to the
post-processing step in which we tried
to make these clusters understandable
for the experts for our stakeholders
okay every one of you understand that
when we have territorial information is
very visual to get a map so that was
already telling something to the experts
because here you can see that my grep is
one cluster south and Africa is another
Cal another cluster southern America the
very south cone is another cluster
except from Paraguay that seems to be
more similar to the Central America and
Eastern with Western Asia has another
profile and so and so we can see there
is some kind of geographical proximity
in between the countries belonging to a
center a certain cluster this is talking
about cultural influence on on the on
the health approach in general even if
we didn't think
into the data set any information about
georeference or about the geographical
location or anything related with that
but it's not enough right so if you are
the president of the mental health
department of the w-h-o and you need to
see if you have to build hospitals or to
send psychiatrists to this kind of
countries this map is not enough right
so one thing is to find the model the
model was found at that point so we knew
which were the clusters which were the
countries belonging to each one of the
clusters we have the results of the data
mining data science of the data mining
processing but this is not supporting
decision-making right so there is a big
gap in between you build a predictive
model and you let a politician to make
something with your predictive model or
not not necessarily a politician the
head the manager of an industry needs
something more than the results of the
model or the blind prediction to be able
to close a production line to open a new
I knew how much five minutes to open a
new a new a new site in another way
right so after that we were going for
some tools that we have been developing
along the years based on what we find
when we are talking with the experts
that were helping us to make
understandable enough the results of the
clustering so that the experts can make
decisions on top of that the first one
we developed many years ago was the
glass panel graph this is a very very
simple idea that means to put in a
single panel there are conditional
distributions of as much variables as
possible in with regards to the clusters
right this for me it's very easily to
identify which are the variables that
behave in a particular way in a
particular cluster which is distinct
from what
happens in other clusters right and so
with that we can move because we have
the information of many variables in a
single page and we can easily understand
which are the in the local interactions
between the variables in a particular
cluster and we can see all these are men
old and diabetic and this is a cluster
of women which is young and is obese or
whatever it is
so in here here we got information about
countries but when you're when your
counterpart is for example a chemical
engineer you can show this conditional
distributions and you can talk on top of
that when your counterpart is a doctor
he's not interested on histograms he is
not interested in conditional
distributions and it's not so easy to
talk on that so we introduced the
further step after that it was we as the
technicians were making the technical
reading of that thing and were labeling
which are the variables that are
significantly high significance and the
general trend we were moving to
something like that
okay we were moving to something like
that then we were asking to experts to
give the semantics of the variables of
the interpretation of the variables in
such formal way this is what we call the
thermometer in that case we were doing
in in manual way now we have that tool
wait a moment that tool that permits the
experts to use a kind of light and
criteria in that case the lighting
criteria was the modernity of the mental
health system okay or the goodness of
the mental health system and they were
providing the graduation where as where
a variable is is housed when a variable
has high values is associated to a
better situation or a worse one
and on the opposite sense and then we
can catch this information automatically
and we can transfer the polarity the
semantics of the polarity of the
variables to the labeling the technical
labeling that we have been making before
so that means that when having
significantly high values means the
system is better we are using green when
having significantly high values the
system is words we are using red and
then we even go to a more high symbolic
abstraction of the problem and we just
forget about the distributions and
that's what we show to the users right
we get that thing then we can permute on
a color based distribution we get that
thing that's what we use with experts to
discuss with them and you need not to be
very much technical to understand that
this is the cluster with scarcity total
scarcity they need everything whereas
this is the cluster that is better
placed right so this is the basis of a
further step that's conceptualization of
clusters users understand what the
cluster means and that's the and that's
the clue then in that case we got an
outcome an additional outcome that was
that all those variables could be
grouped through three main aspects that
were the capacity of the system the
approach this more Hospital based mental
base and how was the policy framework
and this was the basis for building the
ontology on which these seven profiles
are described towards a certain
particular value of these three
taxonomies so now all the mental health
systems on the W Jo are described
through this kind of book view Larry and
of course giving this kind of
description makes a very easy
that experts could identify what to do
in each one of this profile so for those
profiles that have no resources
investment was required for those
profiles with resources but an old
approach training and helping them to
transform to the more social inclusion
approach was required and that was the
impact of this data science so thank you
very much thank you very much for the
talk well interesting topic my question
is about the amount of effort that has
been done on relying on experts because
I saw that in multiple steps you rely on
expert based knowledge and at the time
that you did the experiment I think it
made sense but do you think if you do
that if you redo the experiment to train
the model could you really actually skip
some of the expert based gossip
it's true that working with experts
requires to adapt to the timing of
experts right so and they are not
processing the things at the same
velocity at the same speed that our
supper computers do right but our
approach and now if you if you if you
think now we are moving very much to
this concept of making data science or
making data scientist not a single
person but a multidisciplinary team that
contains the several profiles so this is
more or less an original an incipient
way of doing these so in my research or
in our applications or in our
consultancies we never exclude the
expert from the process so we always
have the technical staff together with a
representative of the expert domain
knowledge in the data scientist working
team in order to get
although semantic knowledge acquisition
all along the process that is the single
thing that guarantees that you are not
doing the wrong things with you with
your data so many many times
we get data and we process it without
knowing what it is so that's that's not
an approach for IOT sensor data for
example okay so when we receive IOT then
we process the IOT and we get some
indicators from the signals or whatever
it is that come to my database and then
we go for next step in which the expert
comes inside right but ignoring the
experts in our experience that's about
30 years long has always the same
consequence that at the end of the
process you send things and they say it
doesn't make sense we cannot do anything
with that right when we are talking
about supporting decision making so when
you want that the doctors change the
treatment were open more beds in the
hospital or close a side of an industry
somewhere when you really want to
support this kind of decisions it's very
difficult that they trust on what you
provide them if the things are not
understandable oh the interpretation is
not part of the processing all along all
along the system yeah I understand that
but just one additional note on this so
I think like for example for feature
selection it could be a joint effort
like yeah I know but only using expert
based knowledge it could be subjective
and in that features are not in that
case you have all those features
selection techniques of dimensionality
reduction that can help in a certain
moment and you can even provide results
on that before making the final
decisions and they can agree or not on
the proposals of the algorithms but in
any case if you base your feature
selection only on the results of richer
selection algorithm you risk that the
important indicators that they use for
seasoning are not present in the final
data set and that's that's that has a
very big damage at the end on the usage
of the model maybe you have two percent
more accuracy on your model but they are
not going to use it so since we have all
these collinearity s and all those high
order interactions between the features
it might happen that another combination
of features that do not contain the
important ones is as well as a predictor
as another one as the the one that the
experts would like to use and so only
using the technical part do not permit
you to discern in between what is useful
for them or what is not useful for them
so my approach is to use the combination
thank you for the talk I'm I have a
comment and the first one is the
difference between the semantic bias
clustering and the full data-driven
clustering in the sense that I see if
you apply a full data driven clustering
you will have the opportunity to
generate new hypotheses of work while
with the other one you are reproducing
existing knowledge and where were to use
one or the other
in fact in I was I was making a big jump
in the in the middle of the of the
presentation because I was not into the
details of the clustering based on rules
but the first iteration of the
clustering based on rules is the blind
clustering without knowledge okay so we
we see at the first iteration if those
if those blind results fit well or not
on the prior knowledge that the expert
has been proposing and then there is a
discussion so they they they must
analyze if these discrepancies are
eliciting to them part of the implicit
knowledge they have or they make no
sense
at all right so at that point we iterate
a couple of three times to refine this
prime apply of knowledge and we end up
to something that might provide a new
view as well because since we are
working on hierarchical clustering well
I have no time to find the slides for
that part but what we do is we have like
the knowledge we mark which elements on
the data set follow which one of the
rules right we build local clustering
for each one of these of these
subdomains let's say and then we suffer
classify all the remaining elements with
the prototypes of those rules
representative let's say so the result
of that can be that two of the rules
merge together in a single cluster
because the expert thought they were
very different things and from the
structural point of be they are not that
different or that one of the concepts
they have been describing becomes
subdivided in different sub clusters
right so still using that prior
knowledge you can generate new profiles
that they didn't thought about the point
is that what you get is consistent with
what it has already been proved by the
previous science okay and if it if there
are unconscious tenses then we can
discuss and we can decide if we accept
the inconsistencies or we just discard
them that's why we work thank you
the other one is related to the
hierarchical clustering how do you set
up the level at which you stop very nice
question
in the dendrogram the vertical the
vertical axis is a graduated axis that
follows the properties of an ultra
matrix and the level of each one of the
nodes is related with the eight arrow
Jenna T of the clustering
the cluster itself right so the protocol
says that you must find a level in which
the discontinuity in between the two
success two successive aggregations is
as bigger as possible and this is
mapping with a technical criteria that's
to optimize the kolinsky heard about
singles in this kolinsky had a birds
index is something like generalization
of the F index from the ANOVA test
that's the kind of ratio between the
between clusters variance divided by the
width in clusters variance right and
this makes total sense because the
variance there is a theorem from the
density from the 50 76 or something like
that
that proves that variances and inner
seas are directly related with the
quantity of information of a data cloud
right so when you are maximizing the
ratio between the between clusters
variance and the within clusters
variance you are maximizing the ratio
between distinguishability of the
clusters and all modularity of each
cluster inside themselves so that's what
you are looking for when you are looking
for clusters to get very omoge n use
groups of objects which are very
different from the other groups right
that's what you are looking for so
maximization of that ratio that kolinsky
halibuts
in that identifies which is the best
level to maximize these these goodness
of the cluster provided that you have to
skip the two cluster level normally
because it's few information provided
you
[Music]